[Music]
such a morbid
imagination bringing dead
things to
life hey she emerges from her cave hello
when do you think you finish this film
with yours I don't
know
what's all that stuff it's called stop
motion animation what do you think it's
a bit boring it's not finished and it's
not boring make a new one a new one yeah
I know better story you want to hear
[Music]
it there's a
girl she's scared
there's someone
coming who's coming the man no one wants
to meet the
Ashman you can bring it to
life what does the ash man do don't be
scared
whatever it is you think you saw back
there it's not
real I don't want to make this film
anymore don't you want to hear the next
bit of the
story I want to go I want to
go what happens when it takes on life of
its
[Music]
own